welcome back to las vegas now in today's
legal minute eric palacios from eric
palacios and associates the sponsors of
this segment tells us what are the
penalties for a hit-and-run accident
i'm eric palacios welcome to the legal
minute this week's question is what are
the penalties for a hit and run accident
this depends on property damage and
injury to others so first if the
property damage is 750 or less and no
one is injured you can face up to six
months in jail in a two thousand dollar
fine number two if someone is wounded or
if the property damage is over seven
hundred and fifty dollars then you're
facing a felony this can put you two to
twenty years in prison and you can have
a fine of two to five thousand dollars
it's important if you suffer an accident
stay put call the police don't hit and
run we'll see you next week on the legal
minute
and you can get more information by
giving eric palacios and associates a
call that phone number seven zero two
four four four seven seven seven
seven
and you can visit their website at
erickvillaciouslaw.com
we'll be right back